de son objectif : remporter
e du Tour.
Déjà dimanche, il avait fait
partie de l'échappée étape. éta.
Vendredi, en route vers la ville
de Saint-Étienne, Houle a tenté
le coup à nouveau. Il n'est pas
À 12 km de l'arrivée,
il a résisté à une attaque
du Danois Mads Pedersen.
Il a collé sa roue à celle
pour pouvoir revenir
sur le DHUGO HOULE,
cycliste, Israel-Premier Tech
- J'étais content d'avoir réussi
à prendre la roue quand il a
ce qui a surpris un peu tout
le monde. Le Bahrein a bien
réagi, Wright. Du coup,
j'ai sauté dans la roue,
- Houle, bien en jambes, a
pris ses relais et relais et rer
le sprint final.
Alors que le québécois menait
lancé son attaque à 311 m de
l'arrivée, et biene, et biene, r
son gabarit, a tenu bon jusqu'à
l'arrivée. Houle a fini 3e.
- Première victoire de Pedersen
sur le Tour de France et dans
un grand tour. L'ancien champion
du monde qui bat Fle.
- Mais bon, dans le final, c'est
clair que contre Mads Pedersen,
à ma grun peu, un peu, un peu, s
satisfait de la façon dont
j'ai couru aujourd'hui parce que
je ne pouvais pas vraiment f
- Du Qué- Du Qué- Du Qué- Du Qul
Premier Tech est troisième!
- Avant cette 3e place, Hugoe
étape du Tour en 2020.
- Dernier effort sur
les Champs-Élysées!
remporté une étape du Tour de
c'est Steve Bauer, en
1988. Très clairement,
Hugo Houle veut être
- Et troisième victoire d'étape.